Film Courage: What is a midpoint reversal?  Chapman University Professor (Dodge College) and Author Paul Joseph Gulino: A midpoint
reversal that is you'll see and we're
talking classically constructed works
but often what you see is this let's say
it's a dramatic piece you're using
dramatic tension so them under the first
act is you have main character wants the
the money that they're owed and the end
of the second act you're going to get
some kind of resolution of that if if
you go with the idea that the they're
going to get it in the end
the resolution of the movie and forget
it the end of the second act is often
the point where it doesn't look like
they're going to get it okay the
midpoint is usually the mirror opposite
looks like they are going to get it it's
just a game of contrasts that the
character tries different things and you
see possible glimpses of outcome now you
get a lien on Toy Story this is a moment
when there a pizza planet and it looks
like they're gonna get home because okay
we're gonna jump in this stroller and
we're out of here
and that's the closest thing yet it
looks like that could be it and then
though the movies gonna be over and then
that's exactly the moment when it goes
the other way and he gets caught by Sid
and they wind up in this horrible
torture chamber
so dad that's that's an example but it's
a an opportunity to give us a glimpse of
how that what the ending could be like
sometimes it's like if it's a tragedy it
could be the high point you know in
classic drama like 19th century that
would be the point where the first half
is character of doing stuff the second
half of the play is stuff happening to
the character whatever they started
doing starts coming back on them in a
tragedy it could be the high point is
the high point you know the mid point is
the high point it's the place where in
going back to Cuckoo's Nest it there
looks like he says I'm out of here in 98
days I've succeeded I know don't have to
go back to the prison and so it looks
like he won okay that's his objective is
I don't want to work and I want to go
back to prison and then he finds out no
yours here forever now you're not in
prison anymore you're here forever and
that changes the dynamics so
oh and Sunset Boulevard he he makes a
decision I'm leaving I'm leaving her
he gets trapped in this life with this
woman at this mansion is he's totally
dependent on her he finally makes a
decision I'm leaving I can't stand this
anymore and he goes out and leaves this
mansion and he goes to a party with all
his friends and he's having a good time
and what happens he gets a call and it's
the woman that he was with has tried to
commit suicide now he's got to go back
so he gets we get this moment where of a
possible outcome he's gonna he gets away
and then it goes down it's a tragedy so
that's the high point and it travels
down it's it's just mid points an
opportunity to use contrast in cinema
contrast works we if the outcome is
positive it could be if the second act
and the second act is negative it could
be positive vice-versa tragedy it works
a different way some people use it as
when they have the idea of the second
act being broken in two or back three
and four and then wait two and three is
in the middle it could be a place where
tension changes and if you're observing
sequences that's the point where you'll
have a break between two sequences but
it's certainly a place when you're
developing a story to look for the
possibilities of how the story could
plausibly end and then you're in your
god you can make it not end there but
look at what the possibilities are you
could also use it as a break point where
you can make a whole new movie this is a
shop around the corner we're in the
midpoint I told you the story
neither character knows
they're in love with the other they
think they hate each other but they're
in love with somebody else and it's a
midpoint one of them figures it out so
the first part of the story is people in
a shop the second part of the story is
people in a shop two of them are in love
and they don't know it okay
the next story we see that's two stories
the next story we see is that same
situation but one of them does know
now what happens and then finally the
ending is both know so it's a way okay
you've got this premise how are you
gonna explore all the different ways
that it could they could go and all the
scenes you could come get out of it the
apartment Billy Wilder is just it's
worth looking at all his movies because
he's a new hot it's a textbook of
screenwriting but the apartment is the
the middle of the story it's again a
suicide attempt
where this person is pursuing this woman
and is very upset because he finds out
she's somebody else and then the second
half of that second act is about
nurturing that woman back to health
after a suicide attempt so it it's a
situation that we get a glimpse of his
life without her in the middle and then
end of the second act we get a glimpse
of him with success without her and then
the third act is the resolution is he
gets her but he doesn't have the job so
it's three very contrasting moments but
again midpoint some people will say Act
one then act to a and act to be divided
it that way and you have kind of a
subtle change in the what the tension is
in the subject matter in the two halves
second act so midpoint oh so midpoint
reversal it depends it could be
depending on how you redefine it if it's
Toy Story the reversal is that he winds
up at SIDS house that's right in the
middle of the story rather than it's a
reversal from what his hope is
reversal of fortune that kind of thing
so
you